uh challenging visa action to me to
climate targets that they have we keep
going over to the coal charts
uh china continues to rely heavily on
coal which is what you just talked about
energy consumption in china by source
you see where they're at look at that
from 65 till today what it looks like
which is insane and then g on the bottom
makes a uh uh prediction about what
they're going to do with coal go a
little lower right there make it a
little bit bigger president xi says
china will face down
coal use from 2026 and will not build
new coal-fired project abroad but some
governments and company campaigners say
the plans are not going far enough
researchers at
chingua
university in beijing say china will
need to stop using coal entirely for
generating electricity by 2050 to be
replaced by nuclear renewable energy
production so okay so that's this part
now on can you pull up the other two
charts that musk put up the two pictures
so here's what musk was explaining and i
want to really kind of get your feeling
on this what does this mean to the
average person that's watching this so
here is what co2 looks like from 1960 to
2015 right
and this is part of the speech that musk
gave you look at this some the average
person is going to be like well that's
not really a big deal but when you zoom
out and you look at it from a thousand
until 2015 that's what it looks like
okay how this has grown in that time
period so
this anybody that looks at this will say
this is deeply concerning on the growth
that we had from whatever 1950s till
today can you unpack this please yes uh
do you want to go to my powerpoint
beginning in my powerpoint i actually
have this same chart i think from al
gore's movie basically uh go uh
keep going keep going keep going right
there
zoom in on that
that's basically the same chart the
second yellow where al gore is is where
his projections are but i believe the
chart you just showed is where that
first yellow dot is that's what
that's
looks intimidating a couple things there
that's ice core data from antarctica and
it's co2 in temperature the red is the
co2 but what gore doesn't mention is
that the temperature leads the co2 so as
the temperature goes up the oceans emit
more co2 he makes you think that co2
then drives the temperature that's point
one
which is a technical point and even his
producer in a children's book reversed
that and said that you know co2 leads
temperature when it's the reverse now go
to the next slide
and that's if you look back further in
the geologic record there you're going
back uh you know millions of years
that's al gore's high point and this is
a key point here and this is in uh
but when you talk to us how many years
back is this this is going back five 700
million years or so i believe that who
gets data from 700 million years ago how
do you do that uh it's based on all
sorts of uh you know basically
data from everything from sediments lake
bed rocks um people have a hard time
believing a book came out 2000 years ago
called the bible and jesus let alone 700
million years ago they could be off on
the year i don't know if they are often
here they're pretty confident in it but
that's a different argument you know
you're talking about young earthquakes i
wonder if they use excel back in the
days like
but here's the key 90 of earth's
geologic history had co2 levels
uh higher than today and 90 of earth's
geologic history was warmer than today
we're in the 10 coldest 10 percent
lowest co2 where actually we've had
scientists testify to congress that we
are in a co2 famine so if you look at it
the earth has been 90 of history has
been too warm to have ice at either pole
we're in the 10 coldest part so what
gore is showing you is a little snippet
of earth's geologic history
uh now go to the next slide what do i
have i think
this is according to noah this is an
actual chart and the biden
administration's up up on their website
showing earth's history much hotter than
today and this is a quote from the noaa
website past temperatures much too warm
for ice sheets or perennials exactly
what i'm saying and they go back 500
million years now you could argue about
that and you know but that you know if
you're going to accept the other science
you get you look at this i agree and you
see that you see the blue chart that's
today that's an idea now if you go again
i think i have the un chart but i don't
know that i do yes this was in the first
united nations report in 1990. look at
the medieval warm period showed it as
warmer than today this is important
because this is what elon musk is using
and what you brought up
we had a scientist named david deming
university of oklahoma come testify
before the united states senate
environment committee in that after that
1990 u.n report which this chart was
featured in the ipcc intergovernmental
panel on climate change
the gold standard if you will
that the un scientists started an email
campaign and started contacting we have
to get rid of the medieval warm period
why would a climate activist scientists
chosen and to work with the united
nations want to get rid of the medieval
warm period well because if current
temperatures are not as warm as a
medieval warm period it's hard to scare
the public about it so that led to the
whole creation of the hockey stick which
was done by penn state professor michael
mann who just recently moved to
university of pennsylvania which was
called statistical rubbish he went
through and used
all sorts of proxy data for climate and
he smoothed out the medieval warm period
he smoothed out
this is just the northern hemisphere
because we don't have real good data for
the southern hemisphere but he smoothed
out the little ice age and he made a
hockey stick meaning the 20th century
showed this great big temperature these
are temperatures not co2 this chart
this was critical because people
need to know that when originally the un
report
the science hasn't changed in the past
you could argue our understanding of it
but then you get into what they did the
lobbying campaign the professors
received an email saying we have to get
rid of the medieval warm period lo and
behold they got rid of it a few years
later with a very controversial chart
that has been roundly attacked even by
people who believe in a climate you know
climate is a huge problem
discredit it and even man michael mann's
own colleagues in the un uh climate gate
emails revealed it so go to the next
thing i don't know if i have any other
chart here yeah actually this is another
this is a chart exaggerating chen global
temperatures in 1880
we always hear this is done by the
greenpeace co-founder patrick moore
who's now a big climate dissenter if you
will
but that's showing you the the global
temperature and i believe that's you
know tenths or half a degree
the key here is when they claim that
things have gone skyrocketing or
unprecedented the hottest year on record
the hottest decade it's with intense
hundredths of a degree
not even measurable it's within the
margin of error within the margin that
they adjust the temperatures it's a
fancy way for them to say you know 2006
is the hottest year on record but it's
not statistically different from 2005 or
two or even sometimes it was 1998 so
essentially it turns into the last 25
years we haven't had since
late 90s
we had very little warming but then if
you go back to the 1970s where they
start a lot of the baselines we've had a
lot more warning because that was a
little ice age if you keep going i
believe i have an epa chart just one
other point on since we're doing charts
keep going a little faster
more more
keep going you'll see it you'll see a
temperature chart uh that's tipping
point well
well that's actually let's stop there
that's a good one there this is i'll
stop here
this is a co2 chart that shows you since
1960 the same chart but here's the other
thing and this is what i focus on these
are u.n meetings the u.n earth summit
1992 you see rio berlin there's kyoto
1997. if you go up you can see paris
that's 2015. you can see the lockdown
everything they've talked about
everything they've tried has failed to
reduce co2 emissions it's all window
dressing it's a fancy way of saying
we need to convert to a technocratic
socialist system in order to control the
climate because
this because capitalism will destroy the
environment but nothing they've done or
attempted to do has had any impact and
roy spencer a climatologist formerly
with nasa said it would take about a 50
reduction in co2 total emissions for at
least a year or more to actually make a
dent so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]